une mine d'uranium à imouraren au nord
du niger ce site est la propriété
d'areva ce jour de mai 2009
le champion français du nucléaire
organise un voyage de presse anne
lauvergeon imagine un avenir radieux
le scénario prévoit la construction d'un
prochaines années d'autant le central
que celles qui ont été construites dans
les 50 dernières années aux quarante
dernières années 250 central du radium
et son uranium
ça ne sert à rien celle que l'on
surnomme atomic anne van un nouveau
concept le nespresso du nucléaire la
centrale et le combustible qui va avec
l'uranium
ici ça c'est d'uranium c'est ça le rni
l'uranium est ou siguiri
tout ce que vous voyez le tout ce qui
est rouge c'est les stériles au dessus
tout ce qui est gris à de l'uranium
dedans alors peut-être pas beaucoup un
sens qu'il va falloir l'extraire
à l'époque c'est la course à l'uranium
spécialiste de l'énergie au journal le
monde jean michel bezat se souvient de
ses années fastes où le précieux minerai
battait des records
2006 2007 l'uranium est en train de
remonter en flèche
on s'attend à une forte demande des
chinois qui ont lancé et qui viennent de
lancer un grand programme de centrales
nucléaires donc la livre d'uranium elle
est très au-dessus de 2 200 dollars
à cette période sébastien de montessus
dirigeait le département des mines
d'areva
je l'avais rencontrée en 2014 lors de ma
première enquête
le plan stratégique d'areva et la vision
je dirais d'anne lauvergeon s'était la
relance mondiale du nucléaire et donc
préparer le groupe areva est capable de
répondre à la demande de nucléaire dont
tous les secteurs d'activité ce soit
dans la mine que ce soit dans
l'enrichissement que ce soit dans la
construction de réacteurs soit dans les
retraitements est donc l'objectif à
l'époque du groupe c'était comment faire
pour sécuriser des nouveaux gisements
d'uranium pour pouvoir alimenter dans le
cadre de la vente de réacteurs des
contrats en uranium mais pour satisfaire
ses ambitions
la compagnie doit racheter à tout prix
des mines et des permis d'exploration
minière areva jette son dévolu sur une
toute petite société dont voici la
brochure ura mines elle a été créée par
un canadien
elle est domicilié dans un paradis
fiscal aux caraïbes lui ramine assure
avoir découvert de l'uranium dans
plusieurs pays africains
la société détient des permis miniers à
bakouma dans l'est de la centrafrique à
trekkopje en namibie
et en afrique du sud ariste kuyl le 15
juin 2007
areva lance une opa sur amine la
compagnie des bourses 1 milliard 800
millions d'euros pour s'offrir 100% de
la société minière et ses gisements
prometteurs
l'acquisition je vais le découvrir c'est
passé dans des conditions très
inhabituel
j'ai retrouvé dans la région d'orléans
un des patrons des géologues d'areva
aujourd'hui à la retraite jean-pierre
millésime explique que les géologues
doivent toujours expertiser le sous-sol
avant l'achat d'un permis miniers
avaient cure amin ça ne s'est pas passé
comme ça quand les géologues ont été
appelés c'était déjà bien engagée au
niveau des discussions et au niveau du
processus d'acquisition il n'y avait
plus la possibilité d'aller visiter les
gisements or pour un géologue ne pas
voir un gisement c'est examiner le
catalogue la redoute vous voyez le
catalogue c'est beau c'est bien mais
vous pouvez pas toucher le produit est
ce que c'était on nous a dit que c'était
trop engagé c'est trop tard et quand on
aura le temps de voir les chaînes et les
zones en question après selon
jean-pierre milesi les patrons d'areva
se sont contentés d expertise du
sous-sol financé par les vendeurs
voici celle de trekkopje 176 pages de
cartes de chiffres et de graphiques qui
met en valeur le potentiel du gisement
nous avons eu ces documents qui nous ont
été présentés comme étant parfait
correct et puis alors bien emballé bien
ficelé très très beau document ça plaît
beaucoup à des noms géologue quand on a
un excellent document de communication
or les gens qui ont regardé le dossier
avant la dernière heure de la dernière
minute la dernière seconde on avait eu
essentiellement du bel emballage qui at
il sous l'emballage
il y aurait il eu tromperie sur la
marchandise le mieux c'est d'aller voir
sur place en namibie à trekkopje où se
situe l'un des trois gisements acheté
par areva
nous sommes à 100 km de l'océan en plein
désert d'oleron go en direction du site
arrivé à la barrière qui délimite le
périmètre de la mine
impossible d'aller plus loin
la seule âme qui vive est un gardien
in the mind c'est bien la mine d'areva
ici mind oui et non pas encore ayez des
gens qui travaillent à personne mister o
ok ok ok ok ou avec des impossible
d'aller au delà pour découvrir le site
seule solution les photos satellites sur
ces images on devine des installations
importantes
je les découvre photographié sur cette
plaquette de la mine publiés par
l'entreprise
areva investi très rapidement dès 2007
afin d'extraire de l'uranium au plus
vite
au total près de 800 millions de travaux
qui viennent s'ajouter aux 1 milliard
800 millions de la chat du rabin
les bâtiments sont impressionnants la
mine a même produit pendant deux ans de
petites quantités d'uranium
cerise sur le gâteau les mines sont
grosses consommatrices tôt areva a
investi 250 millions de dollars dans la
construction de cette usine de
dessalement de l'eau de mer
les canalisations fonctionne et les
usines tournent
clin d'oeil du destin depuis que la mine
est en sommeil
areva vent l'eau de son usine à d'autres
mines dans la région
les bureaux d'areva se situe à 70
kilomètres de là à soi comme unt la
capitale minières du pays
curieuse impression de se retrouver dans
une coquette ville allemande sous les
tropiques dans ce petit immeuble le
siège social d'areva
son directeur accepte de nous recevoir
pour une courte interview une photo
d'anne lauvergeon et de son directeur
des mines sébastien de montessus
témoignent de leur visite en 2009 le
directeur dément que la mine soit
définitivement abandonné la mine de
trekkopje ne produit pas en ce moment à
cause de la chute des prix de l'uranium
en usage quotidien et leurs atouts c'est
uniquement pour cette raison que nous
l'avons mise en sommeil en attendant que
autour de dire à moore monte comme ce
sera le cas on remettra les choses sur
la table et on pourra relancer la
production
voyez vous prévoyez ça pour quand on n'a
pas de date précise
parce que si on est à l'arrêt c'est à
cause de facteurs externes duo tout
étonnant qu'on ne contrôle pas c'est
possible de visiter la mine et il pense
avoir c'est impossible
elles sont pas se voir impossible
à entendre le directeur local la mine
serait temporairement en sommeil le
temps que remontent les cours mondiaux
de l'uranium mais pas sûr que
l'explication soit suffisante
je décide de faire mon enquête de
voisinage toutes les mines d'uranium de
namibie sont situés dans la région à une
soixantaine de kilomètres de trekkopje
le géant minier rio tinto un groupe
anglo-australien exploite l'une des plus
importantes mines d'uranium au monde
racing
à la différence de la mine d'areva la
visite est possible et bien organisée
et ici la mine fonctionne à plein
rendement
24 heures sur 24 quel que soit le cours
de l'uranium
j'interroge le directeur werner duvet
nagl sur la teneur en uranium de la mine
d'areva
quelle est la teneur minimale en uranium
au pouvoir exploiter une mine akkaoui
colonnes il ya un taux minimum ça veut
dire ton en dessous de ce taux ce n'est
pas rentable économiquement en dessous
de 100 oui en dessous de 100 on
considère que ce sont des déchets
en ce qui concerne areva à trekkopje ils
sont juste au sud sont très bas si vous
deviez acheter une ligne dans la région
trekkopje vous lâcher feriez sa teneur
en uranium est très faible des mines
comme celle là on en a déjà
alors on vient d'en acheter pour le
regrette
près de 400 tonnes d'uranium sortent
chaque mois de cette mine
en revanche rien ne sort de chez areva à
quelques kilomètres de là
dans le portefeuille de la société sûrs
amine areva acheter un autre gisement à
bakouma en centrafrique
et là encore le champion du nucléaire
n'a pas fait une bonne affaire
la mine de bakouma est située à 700 km à
l'est de la capitale bangui perdu au
milieu de la forêt tropicale
la zone est très difficile d'accès voici
une des rares photos aériennes du lieu à
bangui nous avons retrouvé un témoin qui
connaît bien bakouma il s'appelle régis
giunta géologue
diplômé de l'école des mines de nancy il
a été salarié d'areva sur le site
le voici avec quelques-uns de ses
collègues
il a effectué des forages dans le sous
sol pour évaluer sa teneur en uranium
ici à la différence de la namibie le
taux de minerais dans la roche est élevé
mais techniquement inexploitables il n'y
a jamais une d'exploitation d'uranium à
bas coûts c'est important de le dire moi
je suis centrafricain je suis géologue
j'ai travaillé avec areva sur le site de
bach mois les travaux là bas se sont
arrêtées en phase du développement
régis giunta est formel jamais un gramme
d'uranium n'est sorti de ce gisement et
quatre ans après son achat areva fermer
le site de bakouma s'il va pouvoir
continuer à jal et qu'on travaille pour
arriver c'est sûr je ne suis pas le seul
à être licenciés
c'est tout le personnel réverse
centrafrique qui a été déposé
l'entreprise française a aujourd'hui
quitté le pays nous allons le constater
en nous rendant sur les hauteurs de
bangui à deux pas de la place valéry
giscard d'estaing où étaient situés les
locaux d'areva
bonjour monsieur bonjour le fils du
propriétaire et là c'est les locaux
d'areva ici c'est ça depuis combien de
temps ça va plus des clients d'accord
et c'était louer et areva payez vous
payez donc famille ah ouais s'ils
payaient combien ici six cent mille six
cent mille francs cfa
super 1000 euros par mois il a pu y a
pas de meubles darchy de quoi que ce
soit en hausse
devant c'est un projet rhénium de
bakouma je regarde tout ça en fait c'est
un peu les mêmes rapports mais jamais à
temps c'est un coffre-fort son nom c'est
quoi ces coffres forts et il ya quoi
dedans y'a rien dans le coffre fort est
vide la mine rachetée par areva n'a
jamais rapporté un sou areva aurait-elle
été victime d'une arnaque
une enquête interne et demandé au
directeur de la sécurité d'areva
thierry d'arbonneau un amiral l'enquète
se concentre autour des vendeurs de la
société sûrs amin un anglais jim mullen
et un mystérieux canadien stephen
d'athènes dont il n'existe aucune photo
les vendeurs du rami n'étaient pas des
cités pas des perdreaux d'années il
était connu dans le monde liés
pas d c'était pas des escrocs sont des
gens qui ont monté en fr une un business
qui n'ont fait en appliquant des règles
qui leur permettait de le faire l'amiral
recrute un détective spécialisé dans le
renseignement économique
ce mail interne à areva en témoigne une
société d'intelligence économique a été
sélectionné vingt mille euros plus les
frais le détective a accepté de nous
rencontrer à genève où il est basé
marc échangées est un ancien trader
une ex star des marchés financiers
reconverti dans les enquêtes privées
l'amiral et son adjoint lorsqu'ils le
rencontrent n'ont que très peu
d'informations sur l'opération durera
mines
il m'explique leur difficulté à
comprendre une opération ura mines dont
ils me disent que quelques bribes sans
plus disons qu'on n'est pas très à
l'aise avec ça on comprend pas trop ce
qui s'est passé qui comprennent pas
tellement l'opération qu'ils ont été un
peu écarté qui n'ont pas eu de regard
sur cette opération la caisse qui est
quand même étonnant une opération à
milliards 8 d'euros peut quand même
faire un petit effort
au cours de son enquête marc échanger va
se pencher sur l'incroyable plus values
qu'ont réalisé les vendeurs grâce à
l'opé assurera mine ils avaient acheté
des permis miniers 35 millions d'euros
deux ans plus tard en profitant de
l'envolée des cours de l'uranium
ils les revendent à areva pour 1
milliard 800 millions d'euros 50 fois
plus cher
le détective découvre que les vendeurs
tellement fiers de leur coup le raconte
dans un ouvrage team and which they une
équipe enrichie comme l'uranium avec ce
sous titre comment vendre une petite
société à un grand groupe
sans complexe il se compare à des
chasseurs de primes du far west qui
aurait décroché le pactole
le détective privé se dit convaincu que
l'entreprise publique a payé sûrs amine
beaucoup trop cher dans son rapport il
conclu il ya un faisceau d'indicés
sérieux et concordants qui démontre qu
areva a été victime d'une escroquerie
je rends mon rapport aux meilleurs la
certitude qu'ils viennent de ce fait
enfler 2,1 milliards 8 et ça vous
découvrez en 2010 ça y est vous
l'écrivez oui et je demande la saisine
du procureur
et est-ce qu'il ya une procédure
judiciaire
à ce moment là à ma connaissance non une
direction juridique à arriver mais je ne
demandais pas si vous voulez ce n'est
pas mon objectif c'est pas mon but mais
man ma proposition c'est de dire
attention il ya toutes ces questions qui
se posent si jamais quelqu'un sans
parler de la sphère qui qu'on n'avait
pas préparé des réponses à ces questions
là on sentirait pas bien si vous voulez
que areva numéro 1 de l'uranium dans le
monde se fait avoir par une junior sud
africaine on a fait des choses plus
vivant plus que cela
je sais simplement que ce rapport a été
transmis au directeur général délégué du
groupe qu'on a informé anneau vert jaune
et ils ont décidé sur la base des
éléments contenus dans son rapport qu'il
n'y avait pas nécessité de d'informer la
justice ou les autorités loin du regard
des juges
l'anc est finie sur le bureau d'anne
lauvergeon sans suite judiciaire en juin
2011 lors de l'audition d'anne
lauvergeon devant les parlementaires le
député marc goua
interroge la présidente d'areva sur
cette étrange opération
en 2007 areva s'est porté acquéreur
d'une entreprise qui s'appelle lui
ramine je crois savoir qu' il n'y a pas
encore un tonnage de d'uranium qui est
sorti de cette opération
voilà certain nombre de questions merci
à anne lauvergeon ne se montre guère
précise dans ensuite lancé un mur amis
nous avons rejeté trois gisements un
gisement des gisements puisque en fait
c'est ses déguisements qu'il faut mettre
en ligne transformé ces gisements en
exploitation pratique voilà donc le
sujet le sujet est tout à fait tout à
fait classique un sujet tout à fait
classique pour anne lauvergeon des
pertes abyssales pour les comptes
d'areva
cette mine syncada soit oui c'est une
catastrophe parce qu'ils ont déprécié
avait eu neuf milliards sur sur les
l'hymne de la société ira mines qui se
racheter un milliard vite
en plus ils ont investi de l'ordre de
800 millions d'euros dans une usine de
dessalement de l'eau de mer
donc tout ça se solde par une perte
effectivement de l'ordre de 2 3
milliards d'aud au coeur des
interrogations
la toute puissante patronne d'areva
pendant dix ans qu'elle sut katell
ordonnée quelle est sa responsabilité
dans ce fiasco
sa gestion de l'achat du rami n'est
gravement mise en cause la cour des
comptes a rédigé en 2014 un document
confidentiel
un pré rapport sur la gestion d'areva il
est accablant pour l'ancienne dirigeante
du groupe nucléaire
ils dénoncent des informations biaisées
ou incomplète des fautes individuelles
des manquements voire de la
dissimulation
la cour a depuis transmis le dossier au
parquet financier
une enquête judiciaire a été ouverte
pour faux et usage de faux et
présentations ou publications de comptes
inexacts
pour préparer sa défense en mars 2016
anne lauvergeon comme unique dans la
presse dans l'article qui accompagne son
interview accordée au parisien
le journal affirme que les fameuses
mines durham in valent bien de l'or le
bilan des trois gisements est excellent
avec près de 88 mille tonnes il est très
supérieur à l'estimation sur laquelle
areva s'était fondée
vingt mille tonnes de minerai de plus
que prêt anne lauvergeon aurait-elle
finalement eu raison d'acheter ura mines
nous avons rencontré un ancien géologue
d'areva qui souhaite rester anonyme
pour lui le tonnage de minerai est une
chose encore faut-il réussir à
l'exploiter oui layton sont là mais sont
ce sont des tonnes non exploitables
mais si ça vaut de l'or mais messieurs
exploiter tout de suite car des patentes
tissé de leur formidable
il faut pas confondre la partie
technique et la communication
beaucoup de gens ont lu cet article on
était haut des spécialistes d'areva ou
d'anciens spithill et radio et ont été
scandalisés c'est ridicule c'est ça n'a
aucun intérêt
le géologue a alerté sa hiérarchie en
2011 il a été licencié pour désaccord
avec la stratégie d'areva
je pense que les gens se sont auto
censuré pour éviter toutes sortes
d'ennuis et livrés tous ceux qui ont
parlé ont des ennuis
parmi elles apportent exide enfin tout
cas nous avait fait partie de ceux là
williams est actuellement dans lequel
circonstances avoir dénoncé le
scandaleux remis et c'est ça qu'ils
écoutaient un poste oui le super coq et
moi durable sur beaucoup d'autres parce
que vous étiez allé sonner aux portes à
dire avec votre dossier un design
grameen y a rien dedans c'est une arme
sur eux
pour l'ancien salarié c'est aussi
l'image d'areva qui a été salie et puis
c'est la crédibilité que l'on a perdu
partout on passe pour des farfelus
maintenant alors que nous étions les
meilleurs équipes nous avions les
meilleures équipes de d'exploration
dominion laquelle référence j'en ai plus
rien si ce n'est la risée du monde
entier a causé cette opération
vous en connaissez des trucs comme ça
l'ancien géologue est un témoin clé de
la faire il a été entendu à plusieurs
reprises par la brigade financière
en mai dernier le juge renaud van
ruymbeke convoque anne lauvergeon
il a sous les yeux sa déposition
enregistrée six mois plus tôt par les
policiers selon votre expertise
quel jugement portez-vous en juin 2007
sur la qualité des gisements du rabin je
n'en avais strictement aucune idée
bien que je sois ingénieur en chef du
corps des mines
je n'avais ni l'expérience ni la
formation ni la compétence me permettant
de porter un jugement sur la qualité de
ses gisements
elle plaide l'ignorance
anne lauvergeon va pourtant quitté le
palais de justice sous le coup d'une
double mise en examen pour diffusion de
fausses informations et publications de
comptes inexacts
elle est soupçonnée d'avoir dissimulé à
l'état les pertes colossales du à
l'achat de la société sûrs amine 21h
elle quitte le pôle financier
mais anne lauvergeon pourrait bien être
éclaboussée par un autre volet de la
faire il implique cette fois ci son mari
olivier fric
les enquêteurs de tracfin la cellule
anti blanchiment de bercy ont repéré les
transactions suspectes lors de l'achat
de la société minière ura mines par
areva cette opération aurait dû rester
secrète
or dans les semaines qui la précède de
mystérieux acheteur acquiert des actions
ura mine à bas prix parmi eux olivier
fric il est bénéficiaire d'une structure
offshore
i'm alone limited immatriculée dans les
îles vierges britanniques un paradis
fiscal
entre le 18 mai le 12 juin 2007 hamelin
n'achète 326 milles action ura mines
puis les revend à la veille de la chat
du rabin par areva bénéfices près de
300000 euros
la conclusion des enquêteurs de tracfin
est sans ambiguïté ces faits pourraient
être constitutif d'un délit d'initié
olivier fric at il obtenu une
information confidentielle auprès de son
épouse anne lauvergeon l'ancienne
patronne d'areva et son mari ont été
entendus par la brigade financière
leurs domiciles perquisitionnés olivier
fric a été mise en examen pour délit
d'initié
le 29 septembre dernier
sébastien de montessus l'ancien
directeur des mines est confronté à anne
lauvergeon devant le juge van ruymbeke
il a été placé sous le statut de témoin
assisté
dans cette affaire d'autres mises en
examen d'anciens dirigeants d'areva
pourrait intervenir prochainement avant
un futur procès